elles seront à chaque coin de rues de la
capitale ou presque les terrasses
parisiennes on s'y installe
on prend son temps on discute on
commande un verre bref elles sont
d'abord un symbole de l'art de vivre à
la française ça permet des dehors déjà
démarré la journée en droit d'en sortir
et c'est très agréable et très important
en ce moment
l'ambiance des terrasses parisiennes la
télé s'y intéresse depuis les années 40
surtout au printemps quand les badauds
profite du soleil sur les champs-elysées
en étant les terrasses de café le salon
dans la rue la rue d'anvers même chose à
saint germain des prés tenez direction
le café de flore à l'époque le tout
paris s'y bousculent l'écrivain jean
paul sartre et à ses habitudes
la chanteuse juliette gréco également là
aussi le lieu est idéal pour y flâner au
printemps le floor par exemple le café
n'ont donc avec ses servants décès
pontife à quelques pas de saint germain
des prés le quartier latin
célèbre pour son panthéon au début des
années 60 les terrasses des cafés sont
rempli d'étudiants parisiens l'heure de
pointe se situe entre midi et deux
heures
et l'affluence est telle que l'on se
demande ce qu'il adviendrait de tous ces
étudiants
s'il n'y avait pas de café pour les
recevoir les étudiants s'y retrouve
il étudie drague et parle de tout et de
rien comme ici au souffle au en 1962
parce que j'aime oslo s'est rencontré
des gens qui font du droit avec qui on
peut on peut discuter
le mans en un sens aujourd'hui avec le
décompte filmant les terrasses seront
encore plus nombreuses dans la capitale
pour le plus grand bonheur des parisiens
c'est une vraie même être remboursé par
la sécurité sociale
[Musique]